So, we're going to finish now
by just talking more about this
amazing immune system we have,
the adaptive immune system.
As I said on Friday,
this is really an astonishing
recognition system that just
plays a key role in us being
able to survive in this world
that's full of bacteria,
and yeast, and fungi,
and viruses,
parasites.
There are things just all the
time trying to do us in,
and the reason we don't succumb
is because we have this amazing
immune system.
And there are several features
about it which I summarized the
other day.
One is its diversity.
It has this incredible ability
to recognize entities,
including things that are
synthesized in a lab that had
never been seen on Earth before.
It's amazing in terms of that
side of it.
Coupled with this is this
incredible specificity.
As I indicated the other day,
for example,
if it was seeing a benzene ring
with a methyl on it,
it might be able to recognize
this, but it could tell the
difference from having the
methyl over here.
It's got that level of
sophistication.
In spite of that,
in spite of the fact that it
can recognize everything else,
it's able to avoid self
recognition,
00:01:37<clear/>
which is a bit of a trick if
you think about it,
that you have a system that's
able to see essentially
anything, including things that
never existed before.
And how does it avoid seeing
all of our molecules,
and all the many,
many things that makes us up?
So, it has to be able to tell
self from non-self.
And then, I also talked about
this memory aspects of the
immune system,
that if you get exposed to a
virus or bacterium or something,
but the first immune response
is relatively weak.
But then if you get
subsequently exposed,
you get a very powerful
response.
And that's the principle of a
vaccine.
If you think someone is going
to be exposed to chickenpox but
they haven't had it,
if you could somehow elicit the
initial response without making
them sick by using a killed
virus or something like that;
polio is one of the examples
you hear about in the paper
right at the moment.
Then, if someone does encounter
that virus or that bacterium,
because that's second response,
it's very quick and it's very
powerful, and that's what
vaccines are all about.
So, the issue,
I guess, today is how does that
happen?
And this is one of these
amazing insights into biology
that's come by an application of
all these tools,
recombinant DNA,
and sequencing,
and all the fancy sort of
things we've been talking about
in the past few lectures.
So, the first part I need to
let you know,
is there are two parts to this
immune response,
or two kinds of responses.
00:03:26<clear/>
One's called the humoral
response and one's called the
cellular response.
And this takes place in the
plasma of your blood.
So, in the liquid part of the
blood if you spin down the red
cells and the white cells,
what you're left with is the
plasma.
And, what this humoral response
response does,
it's able to target bacteria,
viruses, proteins.
00:04:14<clear/>
And the recognition is done by
a special kind of protein called
antibodies.
And I'll tell you about that in
just a moment because they're a
very important class of protein
in this Earth.
And the cellular immune
response is carried out by a
special kind of white blood
cell.
00:05:00<clear/>
For this lecture I think I'll
just abbreviate those as WBC if
I need it.
What this targets is not the
actual pathogen itself.
But it targets cells that are
infected with a virus or a
bacterium, etc.
and that might seem to be even
a little bit more of a trick.
It's hard enough probably to
figure out how to take something
that's an entity like a virus
that's floating around your
blood and figure out how to find
something that binds to it.
What do you do if the thing's
gone into one of your own cells
and it's hiding out in their
replicating in the same way
that, let's say,
a phage does or something like
that
How do you see one of your own
cells that's been infected by
something like that?
And there is a special type of
cells called cytotoxic T cell
that's very important.
It's often abbreviated as that.
So let me first say a word
about antibodies.
These are proteins that consist
of four polypeptide chains.
Two of the chains are bigger.
So they're called heavy chains.
There's two of those.
And there are two chains that
are smaller, so those are
usually called light chains.
So, there's four of them
altogether.
And, ignoring secondary
structure and stuff for the
moment, let me just sort of give
you an idea of how these are
laid out.
These are the two heavy chains.
00:07:11<clear/>
And these are joined together
by disulfide bridges.
You remember disulfide bridges?
If you had two cystines they
can form a covalent bond between
them under oxidizing conditions.
So, those heavy chains are
locked together.
They're actually physically
covalently joined.
In fact, there's the light
chains here.
So, this is the light.
And this part up here is highly
variable between different
antibodies.
And the part down here is
constant between antibodies.
And it's this huge amount of
variability that the body
produces many,
many, many types of antibodies,
and then figures out which ones
will work to find the particular
entity it's trying to recognize.
And I'll come back and tell you
in a moment how that is done.
There is a diagram of what I
showed you, but of course these
are proteins.
They have three-dimensional
structures, and so if you were
to look at them with the
secondary structure showing,
you can see the different,
especially here,
a lot of beta sheets should be
leaping out at you.
Now, the part where the
recognition is done is up at
this end.
So, it's essentially right
here.
And here's a little movie.
You could see how the thing
looks in three dimensional
space.
You see the part that's over on
the left at the moment;
that's the light chain and the
blue chain is that part of the
heavy chain complex with the
light chain.
And here is the,
it's been tilted up this way so
this is the yellow and blue part
you were looking at
And the recognition pocket is
right at the end of that.
And at this picture,
it's showing how a particular
protein was shown in red.
This is an anti-body that can
very, very precisely recognize
that particular protein.
You can't really tell it from
the three-dimensional shape
shown on the left because it
just shows the secondary
structure.
But, if you could see the full
space filling model,
you'd be amazed.
The surfaces are absolutely
complementary.
It goes back to one of those
principles I've said over and
over and over again that so much
of biology works by having
complementary surfaces.
And there's a little movie you
could see how this thing is
setting up there at the top.
So, these antibodies are
produced by a special type of
what are called B cells.
These are cells that play roles
in the humoral part of the
immune system.
And they're called plasma
cells.
And each plasma cell makes one
particular antibody.
And that's it.
So you have many different
types of plasma cells,
but each one only expresses one
particular gene that encodes one
particular antibody.
So, for years,
this is something that people
struggled with just
conceptually.
They could sort of calculate
that there were so many
antibodies that if your entire
genome was nothing but antibody
genes, we still wouldn't have
enough DNA to account for all
this ability to recognize
things.
So, some other principle had to
be involved.
And there are all sorts of
speculations about what it was.
I had shown you,
I'd managed to not get Bob
Horvitz's thing on here,
but this then,
who is our fourth Nobel
laureate, I've been sort of
working through these.
Susumu Tonegawa,
who is in the cancer center,
he's in the biology department.
He's also heading,
now, this Picower Center of
learning and memory.
So, since doing this work I'm
telling you about on the immune
system, he's gone to do some
wonderful stuff more on the big
problem of how we learn,
and trying to get more
molecular insights into that
process.
But what Susumu managed to
figure out was that this
variation and diversity in the
immune system was,
at its roots,
a combinatorial sort of
process.
So, if you look in the DNA of a
zygote, so that's the fertilized
egg.
We're just getting started with
one of our cells.
You've got a single cell.
We're looking in the DNA to see
what would happen.
We come to the part of the DNA
that's involved in producing
antibodies.
What he found was that if you
looked along the DNA,
there were sequences that
looked like part of the stuff
that you'd find in antibodies,
but there were a whole series
of them.
So, he called this particular
segment V1, V2,
V3, up to VN.
There were a whole set of these
basically side by side by side
by side.
There are about 300 of these in
humans.
And then down the DNA a little
bit he found another set of
sequences that are all
variations of each other.
And these were given D1,
D2, D3, D4, up to DN.
And there are many of these.
And then down the DNA a little
farther, there were three other
sections that were called
joining segments.
They were called J1,
J2, J3.
And a little bit farther down
there was a block of DNA coding
the constant part of this
polypeptide chain that goes into
an antibody.
And what Susumu Tonegawa was
able to show,
and this led to the Nobel
Prize.
So, what happens during the
development of these B cells is
there are rearrangements.
And a lot of DNA is thrown
around.
And the basic strategy is to
take, if you think this as being
column A, you take one from
column A, one from column B,
just picking them randomly,
one from column C over here,
and throw away everything else.
So you might have,
for example,
in one B cell,
you might have V32,
D15, J2, and then the constant
region.
And, what's in between is an
intron that will be spliced out
at the time that the gene's
expressed.
In another B cell,
you might have V11,
D22, J3.
So, this rearrangement is
random in the sense of which V
segment is chosen,
which D segment is chosen,
and which J segment.
I don't mean that it all just
joins together in a completely
uncontrolled way.
And then the rest of the DNA is
deleted.
00:16:23<clear/>
So a consequence of this,
is each B cell expresses only
one antibody.
It's true that they're diploid,
but only one chromosome is
expressed.
So that's how they avoid,
you can imagine they might make
to two.
But they only make one.
In the process,
as you can see,
that part is random.
Furthermore,
the joining events are what I
think you could call sloppy.
And this leads to even more
variation than you would have
imagined simply looking at the
number of segments.
So, what this part of the
process does is it explains why
the system can be has the
diversity it has,
because it's using this
combinatorial process.
If you know the number you can
calculate how many possible
combinations there are.
But then there's much more
variation because when it joins
together a little segments that
are joined are done in a sloppy
way so that the DNA sequence
that shows up where the joints
occur doesn't look like anything
that was in the DNA at all.
It was something like a
polymerase that wasn't very
faithful copying and making
mistakes as it went along.
So what the system does,
is it doesn't get you a
response.
It just explains why there is
so much diversity,
and why it is that I can go
into the lab and synthesize a
compound that's never been on
this earth before,
inject a rabbit to it,
and the rabbit will probably
produce an antibody that's able
to recognize that.
That's because it's made this
whole set of them.
And they all are going to have
somewhat different surfaces.
And they make so many that one
of those surfaces is going to
fit the molecule that I'm
testing.
You can sort of see,
that's only part of the trick.
So, how do you now get an
immune response?
Because you've got millions of
these things.
But what you now need is a
whole lot of one particular
antibody that's going to
recognize the pathogen that you
are being exposed to.
And the principle of that is
really cute.
It's a process called clonal
selection.
00:19:29<clear/>
And the idea is that each B
cell displays
00:19:48<clear/>
a sample of its antibody on its
surface.
So, we might think of it this
sort of way, that after this
process is through we have one B
cell.
Of course, these are way out of
proportion.
The cells would be huge,
and these would be molecules.
So, they're small.
But here would be an antibody
that can recognize squares,
say, this one would have an
antibody that could recognize
triangle.
This one would have an antibody
that could recognize a
semicircle and so on,
millions and millions of
different shapes.
And these cells don't divide,
though.
They've been made,
and they just sit there.
And then, when you stimulate
them with an antigen,
and I used that word the other
day, an antigen is just anything
that will elicit an immune
response.
It could be a piece of a
foreign protein,
carbohydrate,
just about anything that's a
small molecule you've made in
the lab.
But let's say we exposed now
this individual to an antigen,
which in this case can fit into
that receptor.
And what happens,
then, this one becomes
stimulated to divide.
So what we have now is this B
cell that has this antigen stuck
into its binding pocket on the
sample of its antibody.
And then, the cells divide and
they give rise to two
populations.
They give rise to the plasma
cells, which are very
short-lived, on the order of a
few days.
And what these do,
so they would look like this,
what they do is secrete
antibodies into the plasma.
So what you end up with,
then, are a lot of these
antibodies that have exactly the
specificity that the original
sample had on the outside of
that particular B cell.
This takes a few days.
So back when we were talking
about the discovery of DNA,
I was telling you about
Streptococcus pneumonia,
and you get infected by the
Streptococcus.
And there would be this period
of five or six days where this
person was very sick,
and then either they'd survive
or they didn't survive.
If they survived,
they'd been able to mount an
immune response and make these
antibodies before they got
killed by the bacteria.
And the reason it takes a few
days is when you start out there
could be just one B cell that's
able with an antibody,
makes an antibody that is
capable of recognizing the
capsule.
Maybe there are a few.
Anyway, but they were very,
very tiny number,
and there were probably a lot
of bacteria.
So what had to happen,
then, is that the original cell
or small number of cells that
could recognize the
Streptococcus had to be
amplified.
They had to make a lot of
plasma cells that have the
potential to make the antibody,
and then they had to secrete
the antibody into the plasma.
And I'll tell you in just a
minute some of the strategies
that that uses to help kill the
pathogen.
And the other population,
just before I go on there,
are what are called memory
cells.
There's not as many of these
made, but they're very
long-lived.
And so, what they have is
exactly the same capacity to
make the same antibody,
but they're not actively
dividing.
They'll just sit there,
float around in your
bloodstream, and then if you get
a second exposure to the
antigen, you get a very fast and
strong response because the
selection for finding the cells
that had antibodies that can
recognize the antigen has
already been done.
And there's already a few of
them around, and then after you
do that then you're able to
make, once again,
the binding of the antigen
stimulates these guys to start
dividing.
They make a lot of plasma
cells.
And going back to the principal
of vaccination,
your first response is fairly
modest.
But if you get a second
response, what you're doing now
is the memory cells are already
there.
They have the specificity for
recognizing the antigen in
question.
And you can make a whole lot of
them.
So, if you had chickenpox when
you were little,
you have memory cells that know
how to recognize the chickenpox
virus.
And then when your kid gets
chickenpox like mine did,
I didn't get sick because I had
memory cells that were able to
recognize that.
OK, so what happens if you get
an antibody?
How does this help the
organism, or in our case someone
like you or me,
avoid getting sick?
So there are a couple of
strategies.
One we might think of is bind
and block.
For example,
you are a virus and you get
covered by antibodies.
Viruses: it's exactly the same
logic as bacteriophage,
except that instead of
affecting a bacterial cell a
virus would be infecting one of
our cells.
And as the virus has receptors
or something,
it has to recognize something
on my cell, in order to attach
and then to inject its DNA.
So if we've got an antibody
sitting here,
then it can't find its way to
the host cell.
And then, there are a couple of
other ways.
They can target for
destruction.
And there's basically two ways.
There's something called the
complement system,
that if it is able to
recognize, say,
the bacterial cell and their
antibodies are sticking to the
outside, what the complement
system does is it's able to make
little pores in the membrane of
the pathogen.
And I think one of the things I
hope you will remember is that
one of the secrets of life is
that we have to keep that
membrane around there.
We have to keep all of our
insides in, and the rest of the
world outside.
We have hydrogen ion gradients
across the membrane.
So, if you want to kill a cell
and you, say,
insert a protein that has a
little hole and it,
and that thing sits and sticks
in the membrane,
that cell is dead.
It can't maintain an ion
gradient, and things can leak
out through the hole.
So that's one of the ways of
killing it.
The other ways are macrophages.
These are a type of white blood
cell, as well,
are very good at recognizing
bacteria that have antibodies
stuck to the outside.
And in fact,
that was the principle of that.
We have the Streptococcus,
and we have the capsule.
And you may remember that
little movie I showed of a white
blood cell that was trying to
eat it, and it couldn't get hold
of the thing,
whereas we saw another example
where a bacterium without a
capsule, there was sort of
principle I said is that the
white blood cell was able to
recognize the bacterium and then
it pinches it off inside of a
membrane bubble.
And I sort of said at least in
principle that there is another
little bubble with poisons,
and it brings it together so
that you have the bacterium and
the poison together inside of
some intracellular compartment,
so that macrophages know how to
kill a bacterium if they bring
it inside.
The problem in the case of
something like Streptococcus was
being able to recognize it
because it couldn't get hold of
that capsule.
So, those antibodies that guy
made during that five day thing
decorate the outside of the
capsule because their
specificity is to recognize the
capsule and bind to it.
But a macrophage,
even if it couldn't get hold of
the bacterium with a capsule is
able to ingest something that
has antibodies stuck on the
outside.
And once it gets inside,
it can kill the bacterium.
In fact, immunologists call
this process opsinization,
which is derived from the Greek
words for seasoning,
like putting salt on your food.
And the idea was that when they
were giving that word,
with these macrophages,
which liked to eat bacteria,
they have a little seasoning
that they have these little
antibodies decorating their
outsides.
So here you can see it least in
the humoral response how you
generate a whole lot of
diversity.
Then this principle of what's
called clonal selection
identifies a B cell that's able
to make an antibody that can
recognize the particular
pathogen or molecule that you're
being exposed to amplify that,
make a lot of antibodies,
and then it can either just
stick to the pathogen like a
virus and mess it up that way,
or it can decorate it if it's
something like a bacterium,
and then pull in a couple of
other systems that are capable
of killing the pathogen.
I mean, it's an absolutely
amazing system.
It sounded like science fiction
when I first heard about it.
When I heard people talking
about it, everyone could see
there was an information theory
problem.
How do you encode all that
information with just this
amount of DNA in a cell?
Now we understand.
And there's even another part
that I'm leaving out here.
But once this whole thing has
been selected,
there's another whole round of
sort of refinement where the
cells do kind of a very kind of
localized mutagenesis one base
pair at a time in the vicinity
of this binding pocket.
And they're able to make,
if they're given more time and
more exposure to the antigen,
they can make a better and
better binding surface until you
begin to approach sort of the
theoretical maximum.
Now, the T cell,
in this case this involves the
cytotoxic T cells,
and they have a specific
recognition molecule on their
surface.
It's called the T cell
receptor.
And in this case,
it's attached.
So, this is the membrane of the
T cell.
And this is the cytoplasm down
on this side.
There's a little bit of the
protein that goes into that.
And then there's an alpha helix
that goes through,
and then a segment that comes
up like this.
And there's another chain that
does the same thing.
So, there are two segments that
span the membrane.
This thing is anchored in the
membrane.
And then it's essentially the
same principle as with
antibodies.
There's a variable region,
and there's a constant region.
And to a first approximation
anyway the logic by which the
cell generates a huge,
diverse set of T cell receptors
is the same logic that underlies
the generation of a whole lot of
different antibodies by taking
segments, joining them,
picking them randomly out of
column A, column B,
and then joining them together,
sloppy joining all the other
processes to increase the pool
of diversity.
Now, what these B cells are
able to do, then,
these T cells are able to do is
something quite remarkable.
We have on our cells,
this is, say,
one of my cells,
little sort of proteins that
function as sort of display
cases or something.
And what they do is they show
samples of all of the different
proteins that are inside us at
any given moment.
Proteins are turned over,
and chopped up,
and things are recycled and so
on.
So there are always little
peptides, little pieces of
proteins around.
And, the display case,
if you will,
has got a major
histocompatibility complex,
which is usually abbreviated as
MHC because it's such an
unwieldy name.
And there are many,
many alleles of MHC in the
population, which means that we
each have, for the most part,
a sort of individually designed
display case for showing these
peptides.
The property of these display
cases, they take some little
piece of a protein just a few
amino acids long,
it binds into the display case,
and that sticks on the outside
of our cell.
And so we have a lot of these.
And so on the surface of our
cells are these little
individualized MHC display cases
showing little samples of the
peptides of the proteins from
the proteins that are inside us.
So, if everything is fine,
all of the peptides that are in
the display cases are our own.
And I'll tell you in a minute
why that doesn't cause a
problem.
But then if you get infected by
a virus, and it injects DNA or
its RNA inside of you and then
starts to replicate,
now you have some virus
proteins that don't belong to
you.
They get chopped into pieces,
and they begin to appear on
these major histocompatibility
display cases.
So if you think here,
this could be,
perhaps, a little piece of,
let's call it self protein,
it could be a little piece of
my own DNA polymerase or
something like that.
And over in this one,
let's say we have a little
piece of a viral protein.
So that's something that would
not be normally there.
So what this T-cell receptor
does is it recognizes,
so this is non-self or foreign.
What the T-cell receptor does
is it recognizes these foreign
peptides.
But it does it in the context
of the display case.
Otherwise the peptides would be
floating around.
So, in essence,
the T-cell receptor,
if this is a cytotoxic T cell
it's able to see the individual
display case with a bit of viral
protein in it.
And then it knows that it
should kill that cell because
it's got something in it that
shouldn't be there.
I mean, it's a brutal but very
effective strategy.
If we applied it here,
I go around if I found any of
you had a cold,
I could just take a gun and
shoot you and it would cut down
on the number of sick days for
the rest of us because it
wouldn't spread the infection.
But in essence,
at a molecular level,
that's the strategy.
Try to identify a cell that's
got something inside it that
shouldn't be there,
and then the cytotoxic T cells
kill that.
And let me just show you a
couple of quick movies of this.
At this point,
these will be the last protein
structures you're going to see
from me, I think.
Here's a representation of that
T cell just as a cartoon as you
see it in a textbook.
Here it is.
This is the binding pocket up
here.
And there's a little tiny
peptide, nine and amino acids
from the HIV virus bound in
here.
Somebody did a crystal
structure, and was able to work
that out.
And, if you look at it in three
dimensions, you'll see how
beautifully this little binding
pocket and the peptide lies in
there.
So that red part is the piece
of chalk, and the other part is
what I'm describing as my hand.
It's not a bad analogy,
actually, even on a structural
level.
And then, here's another
representation.
This is sort of showing the
hand with a piece of peptide in
it.
And then the T cell is able to
see this whole thing in
recognize it.
And, if you look at it in a
structural form,
here's the little peptide.
This is the part,
the display case you're looking
at.
And here's the T cell receptor
now fitting down in seeing the
peptide in the context of this
major histocompatibility
antigen.
And again, these things are all
beautifully complementary a
three dimensional level.
Again, at the heart of this is
the principle of complementary
surfaces fitting together that
underlies so much biology.
What's this?
This is a tumor cell.
These are cytotoxic T cells
that have recognized this tumor
cell is doing something it
shouldn't that a normal cell
wouldn't do.
And it's attacking it,
and it's killing them.
So, not only does the cellular
immune response help us against
things like infections from
virus and bacteria,
it also will help prevent
cancer.
So obviously there must be some
trick here to why we don't see
our own peptides.
This is the self versus
non-self And it's a relatively
simple principle.
So, distinguishing self versus
non-self is a problem throughout
this whole part of the immune
system.
And here's the principle.
During embryogenesis,
the cell makes,
the organism I guess,
makes the assumption.
I mean obviously it's not
thinking about it.
This is a way of understanding
what's happening.
It makes the assumption that no
pathogens are present.
Any B or T cell recognizing
something must be recognizing
itself.
And so, it deletes those B and
T cells.
This process is given a name.
It's called education.
And it happens in this organ
called thymus.
So, and then after birth,
then it switches.
And now B and T cells,
if they recognize something,
the body makes the assumption
it must be a pathogen.
And it goes after it.
We have this huge human disease
where that goes awry:
rheumatoid arthritis,
or multiple sclerosis are cases
where the self versus non-self
recognition has broken down.
OK, so for example multiple
sclerosis, a very difficult
disease, because there's a
gradual deterioration of the
nervous system.
And what happens is the body of
the person with that mounts an
immune response against the
sheath that covers the nerves,
and then that sheath gets
destroyed, and that the nervous
system, somebody with multiple
sclerosis, starts to break down.
And so, if you lose this self
versus non-self you get what's
called an autoimmune disease.
You may have heard that phrase.
It's very important.
It's a very tough thing if you
have one of these.
But that's what lies at the
heart of it.
And people still don't know,
but there is certainly some
evidence for some of these that
are triggered by a bacterial
infection.
So, it could be that perhaps
maybe a bacterial protein looked
close enough to one of your own
proteins, that somehow you got
antibodies against the
bacterium, and then it turned
out it could also recognize
something in your body.
There are some other immune
diseases you probably heard of,
the baby in a bubble kind of
thing.
There are a few people who were
born who have no immune response
at all because one of the basic
pieces for doing those DNA
gymnastics I talked about isn't
there.
Those people have no B cells or
T cells.
They die unless they are
absolutely shielded from
everything else.
And that's one of those cases
when gene therapy,
if you could get that gene into
that person, they'd have an
immune system and they could
live.
There are other kinds of immune
deficiencies that are less
extreme, but nevertheless,
people will be susceptible to
infection.
The other one which I've
already talked about,
but now you can see in another
context is AIDS,
Acquired Immune Deficiency
Syndrome.
And I told you what the HIV
virus does is it injects its
RNA.
That makes a DNA copy.
It goes into protein.
The cells that it affects our
special type of T cell called T
helper cells.
What they are doesn't matter so
much, but what's important to
know is they're needed for both
branches of the immune system.
They play roles in the humoral
response and cellular response.
So, someone who gets infected
with HIV, what happens is the
virus is replicating in these
helper T cells.
And so their immune system is
slowly, slowly being knocked
away.
And the last thing,
which I won't have time to talk
about, but if you have an
allergy, that's an overreaction
of the immune system.
So this is my last lecture.
I've got to let you guys go.
It's been a true pleasure to
talk to you; A real honor to
meet many of you.
And many of you put a lot of
effort into those little
answers.
I really, really appreciate
that.
For those who'd rather not be
here, I hope that somewhere down
the line when you're confronted
with a medical situation dealing
with your parents,
your child, yourself,
whatever it is,
that some of the stuff that you
heard will reemerge to help you
with those decisions.
And I wish you the best of luck
for the rest of the course,
and the rest of your careers at
MIT and beyond.
Thanks very much.
And as I leave,
too, I've had the pleasure of
just having an incredible
teaching staff.
I don't think you guys know how
hard they work behind the
scenes, but thanks to all of you
for being with me.